مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد الرحمن مطار من
اقليم السند هل لديه المزيد من المعلومات
الى كعب الرحمن من جديد
[تصفيق]
نعم عبد الصمد بحسب همم بيان مقتضب منشور
على موقع تويتر فان حركه طالبان باكستان
هي التي تتبنى الان رسميا همم التنفيذ هذا
الهجوم في مسجد بيشاور الذي وصل عدد
ضحاياه حتى الان 20 قتيلا بين العدد
الاكبر منهم هم من رجال الشرطه وايضا ان
العدد الاكبر من من الجرحى هم ايضا من
رجال الشرطه الذين كانوا يؤدون صلاه الظهر
في هذا المسجد المجاور للمقر الرئيسي
للشرطه في مدينه بيشاور اذا حركه طالبان
باكستان هي التي تتمنى الهجوم وايضا هناك
ارتفاع لعدد الضحايا بحسب هذه المعلومات
التي وصلتنا همم للتو اا وبالتاكيد النقطه
التي كان قد اشار اليها ضيفك ربما هي التي
استغلها اليوم همم من نفذ هذا الهجوم
الهجوم استهدف مسجد وعاده لا يتم همم
تفتيش او فحص من يدخل لاداء الصلاه داخل
المسجد وتحديدا في الايام الاعتياديه ربما
بعض المساجد تتخذ بعض الاجراءات الامنيه
يوم الجمعه لكن بالتاكيد معظم المساجد لا
تتخذ اي نوع من انواع الاجراءات الامنيه
طيله ايام الاسبوع خلال الصلوات
الاعتياديه وبالرغم من ان هذا المسجد امه
او معظم من معظم مصليه ومن يؤمهم من رجال
الشرطه لكن بالتاكيد ليست هناك ربما
اجراءات امنيه وهذه ربما الثغره التي تمكن
من تمكنت من خلالها حركه الطالبات باكستان
الان بحسب تبنيها لهذا الهجوم من الوصول
الى هذا المسجد وتنفيذ الهجوم واستهداف
الشرطه
نعم طيب اذا اذا
متواصل الى جهاز الشحمه والعملين في قطاع
الشرطه منذ عده اسابيع اذا كما قلت حركه
طالبان باكستان تتبنى
تنفيذ هذا الهجوم على هذا المسجد
الذي قتل فيه 20 شخصا كما قلت